you think the super bowl's big check
this out each year hundreds of millions
of people worldwide watch the uefa
champions league finals it's the
deciding match of the most prestigious
soccer tournament in europe this year
powerhouse real madrid takes on the
mighty liverpool tomorrow in a game you
will see right here on cbs and on
paramount plus cbs sports host kate abdo
joins us from the site of the big
matchup the famous stad de france just
outside of paris good morning kate let's
just get to it for people that don't get
it why is this match so important
oh i mean you said it's bigger than the
super bowl right there's not many
sporting events that you can really say
that about i i think if you think about
the champions league as a whole it's the
tournament that has been running the
entire season long it's played by the
best teams in europe you have to finish
in the top two three four of your league
to be able to even play in the champions
league so all the best teams play uh
they then play in a knockout tournament
uh throughout the whole season the the
last two standing as you say at
liverpool and real madrid so they are
now playing for what is considered the
biggest prize in club football you're
going to see the best players in the
world playing in this game two of the
best coaches in the game two of the most
storied and most decorated clubs in
world football in liverpool in real
madrid in terms of
if you think about the prizes that
players want to win the champions league
is it this is the one that the players
really want to have on their record
it's always you said it's storied
rivalry here or history between these
two clubs give us a sense of what this
means in the rivalry this game
yeah i mean i think that the reason or
one of the reasons that this game is so
interesting is because it's the same two
teams that met back in 2018 in liverpool
and real madrid real madrid won that
edition of the champions league but it
was a game that kind of left a a bit of
a bitter taste in liverpool's mouth for
a couple of reasons one of the reasons
being that their star player at the time
most uh was was was left unable to play
the majority of the game after kind of a
cynical play by one of the real madrid
defenders took down mo salar and mosul
ended up with a dislocated shoulder had
to leave the field there was also kind
of an issue around the goalkeeper for
for liverpool football club and they
ended up um
seeing that their their goalkeeper make
a couple of very strange mistakes shall
we say there were later some tests on it
was found out that he had a concussion
and perhaps that contributed to why he
had such a poor performance which
essentially ended his career at the club
so i think there's this kind of sense
that there's now a score to settle for
liverpool they really have something to
prove against real madrid who are so
successful in this edition so for
liverpool to then go in
sorry kate i'm going to cut you off i'm
sorry i'm sorry we are out of time i
hate doing that to you but you gave us
some intrigue for people to watch we
certainly appreciate it the uefa
champions league final you can watch it
is liverpool versus real madrid it kicks
off tomorrow three eastern noon pacific
right here on cbs and our streaming
service as well paramount plus you can
watch pre-match coverage with kate and
cbs sports team at 1 30 eastern 10 30
pacific